hey texas new york philadelphia take the
jolly ranchers out of your ears and
listen up because the keep it moving
tour is coming your way yeah guys uh
it's a stand-up show when we play ayg
with the audience it's a good time uh
september 21st will be in san antonio
september 22nd we're going to be in
houston september 23rd to the 25th we're
going to be in austin for the moon tower
comedy festival ever heard of it
then uh dallas fort worth on september
26 and we're bringing it back up north
baby uh september 30th we're going to be
in long island
and then
what are we doing if we're going home
for cheese steaks
whiz wit baby october cheesesteaks and
vengeance october 27th we're gonna be at
helium comedy club in philadelphia get
those tickets they're gonna move fast
i'm telling you yeah do it yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
ready to rock and roll t-bone says ready
we're ready here we go
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grow up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day down
here in auntie's basement i ran into her
last night yeah what she's have to say
jumped in front of my uber
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of ru garbage
he is an international businessman he's
my best pal in the whole world and i
love him i'm gonna tell you that right
now
give it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to see i was with you last night
you had a couple of bud lights and
started hugging me a couple of bud
lights a couple of [ __ ] couple of
teenies he put his head on my head he
goes i'm with you till the end buddy
like you son of a [ __ ] that's private
guys thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are screwed through the [ __ ] roof and
then
there's this website i've heard about
i forg it's not google it's not fake
patreon.com check out mankind's greatest
achievements
patreon.com shout out to mr yam and the
yam family for developing the greatest
website guys go to you can sign up on
patreon.com and get uh a whole bunch of
bonus content check it out absolutely
have a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire yeah t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen what up boys left
the batteries on the table
[ __ ] up they asked you about them 10
minutes should they be in the camera oh
no sorry i was too busy getting my
license i could be your designated
driver you [ __ ] booze bags
these boys got [ __ ]
yeah well gang that is neither here nor
there
i don't know why you're airing out our
dirty laundry in the intro
youtube chatty kathy's over here zip it
will you
get the business gang we could not be
more excited to have our incredibly and
i mean incredibly special guest here
with us today she is a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian actor and
podcaster she was the host of 42
episodes of bravo's hit chat room and
also appeared on 44 episodes of summer
house she is the host of the wildly
successful podcast burning in hell but
the big question in everybody's mind
today is she garbage
i think she boarded you're a reality tv
star yeah i was like why are we even
going through this very happy tv what do
you want me to say ladies and gentlemen
hannah berner
thank you for having me guys i love how
your producer also produces your life
you're like this needs to be produced
get me home yeah
figure this out figure it out hold me on
youtube which wire goes where get me
home
the kid's on the wagon we go out to
dinner we have a couple of pops he gets
a little antsy yeah
so the question is how garbage am i is i
think the better yeah what's the origin
story where do you hail from what's the
deal because i can see your borderline
where do you guys think i hail from in
the united states which state i would
say jersey that was offensive
okay i was born in brooklyn new york
real you're a new york kid i'm a new
york kid i was barn born in park slope
no [ __ ] my grandpa was there in the 70s
he was a basketball coach like one of
those guys in the movies who's like
you're going to become a star yeah and
then the neighborhood got really bad and
all the white people went to go to long
island and my grandpa's like i'm staying
with the kids yeah and then my dad got
beat up every day
that worked out for everybody and then
park slope got super nice now it's like
the yeah it's written yeah my grandpa
moved out to long island later in life
and i was raised in that brownstone i
say like hey arnold that kind of right
yeah yeah and um yeah so that's my
origin i would have thought when you
since you asked i would have thought
uh long island maybe towards the
hamptons i was thinking father a doctor
mom a lawyer no that kind of vibe no my
dad is in sales um he works from home he
like sleeps a lot pets or cats
a real go-getter
i mean he yeah i don't know why he had
to throw him under the block yeah
everybody's got the likes my dad
could be doing more
wait hold on
so your grandfather
gave you guys the brownstone that that
that your dad grew up in he basically
you grew up in the house your father
grew up in yes so i grew up in his
bedroom but my dad's funny my dad is
very a very funny guy and he's kind of
outsmarted the system where he's like i
don't [ __ ] with subways i don't [ __ ]
with people i'm working from home so he
originated the whole like quarantine
vibes yeah he was doing it
yeah he was flattening the curve years
ago when did your grandfather move out
to long island when yeah like was that i
love i love how detailed we want this on
we want it i'm gonna say
late 80s
he moved to shelter island which is a
tiny island jesus christ
i know exactly where it is you do yeah
it's by greece across the world
greenport you have to get on a ferry
like they really make it hard for people
to get out there yeah he's hiding from
that's old-school [ __ ] yeah but what i'm
saying is when you grew up you that was
your house that was our grandfather
didn't live with you but he owned it we
were like taking care of the tenants
like when something would break it
definitely was haunted it was a very old
house a lot of creeks but it was it was
our thing we loved it and my mom was a
principal of a middle school in brooklyn
right there we go yeah yeah
sisters i have one younger brother how
far away he's two years okay he's more
straight and narrow corporate america
very smart nice engaged has his [ __ ]
together and now the neighborhood's nice
and that brownstone's probably worth a
couple of blocks so we
we got to the point where the inside is
falling apart so you either have to redo
the whole [ __ ]
classic new york [ __ ] classic new yorker
on the inside we're all falling apart of
course and probably all he talks about
is how much it's worth i get a million
yeah i get 70 million for that you see
the park out the front door the door
doorman building it's a wrap but still
my parents do that
my parents do that now too because
they're like at retirement age and like
you know the way the housing market is
and like houses are going left to right
in their neighborhood they're walking
around like they're casino pit bosses
yeah like down the street 200 grand down
the street 300 grand but my dad's so
funny this is incredible purchase by a
gym teacher it was like 20 grand when he
bought it and my dad's like why don't
you buy a [ __ ] building and tribeca
yeah yeah
you know he scraped his whole life
savings together as a [ __ ] gym
teacher a guy saving the neighborhood
one one one one youth at a time and then
his kid breaks his balls that you didn't
buy an office building
we could have had chelsea piers come on
jesus christ
that's such a new york thing too so what
happened is we
we were like either we put all this
money in that we don't have to refurnish
the whole [ __ ] place which was
haunted
or i mean i like that that's garbage how
you said that refurnish yeah
you mean redo yeah who the [ __ ] knows i
don't watch hgtv yeah it's got good
bones in it
a couple of couches in there we'll get
12 million for it the outside had these
carvings and structures and there was
like wooden carvings inside italian
whatever i don't know i didn't listen
but it was nice
and so we sold it for like
yeah he sold it for i'd say a couple
million
but then a dude bought it
gutted it yeah and then resold it for
like 10 million yeah yeah but like it's
it's sad that like my house is gone like
that the rich people like
like we lived in it for so long and i'll
walk by it and i'll just be like you're
not the same i'm not the same
yeah so yeah do they where does he live
now what is your mom and dad so my mom
and dad just retired shelter island but
they lived in long island city for a bit
oh they moved out there too they
followed your grandfather
yeah because they got a house there too
oh this guy is [ __ ] leeching off his
own
what the [ __ ] man hey pop we're back
let me get i'm trying to get away from
you
probably get 14 15 million for this
place i love that this has become a real
estate podcast that's it
this is the nitty gritty this is what we
like what was your dad's sales what was
what was he selling um oh he was okay
one
he's so he worked with big data i don't
really listen yeah you know this goes
into my theory that most girls don't
know what their dad does for a living
i take a poll no but i'm gonna argue
this [ __ ] doesn't know what he
does for a living he's very it's like
when lawyers have to do a case he helps
them like look through data and sift
through it
it's just some like fancy college did he
go to college he did okay he went to a
couple he went okay my dad's trash
but my dad has slept like he's living
with his dad this is not the way i saw
this going my dad went to four different
colleges my mom went to cornell oh my
god he we joke all the time my dad
lucked out but my dad is good looking
and funny and like has charisma i get it
i get it so i mean you guys get it like
how do you guys get how the [ __ ] do you
guys get laid like it's you know so
anyway you get it oh we got quiet there
i'm i'm i'm currently married to a woman
way out of my league who paid for this
room so we're going to keep it moving
no comment next question
i got a cornell type thing going on too
so yeah he did good he did good
that's funny
it's shocking how good a sense of humor
goes
truly is yeah i'm not and i completely
understandable right now
all right so did you go to public school
private school so new york new york
depends on where you where you land
we're gonna go into it so i went to
public school and i became
a tennis player
oh that's right he's playing tennis you
were a good tennis i was a good tennis
player really when i was like what do i
not look like no i didn't say that
take it easy a judgey judgey no i just
got the sweater that's so funny when the
heat's turned around on you huh
some would say you're burning in hell
right
so i started playing talking about my
sex life
or lack thereof or lack there's an
outrage
you suck at tennis [ __ ] i'll play you
right now like where they got
[Laughter]
so anyway my dad was like very sports
dad like when i was young he was like
tossing balls at me to work on my hand
eye yeah i was walking at like nine
months old like he was like we have the
next arena and then at like eight years
old my brother quit he had to scam the
scam
he's like we're gonna make quick money
with this kid
she could be pro by she's 12. so when i
was eight years old i finally was like i
really want to do this and a coach told
my parents she's too old to ever go pro
jesus at eight and i wait what do you
mean you're too old like as in like
where she is right now you're already
being high she's not on track so my
parents tell me that wow yeah their
parents were crazy apparently i sobbed
all day like they were like we didn't
even know this kid cared about tennis
but i like hated that someone told me i
couldn't do something so my crazy ass
was like now i need to prove this person
wrong and i don't care if it takes 20
years at eight you're thinking like this
jesus christ so i'm never gonna cross
you i'm a cup of decaf will you relax
watch some [ __ ] cartoons eat a bowl
of cereal go out in the park go see what
doug's up to i was listening to like
space jam soundtrack rocky soundtrack
you guys like rocky yeah
we were we were like jogging and
stretching like it was my dad and our
dream together and by
by
14 i was ranked top 15 in the nation
okay
and i had moved from a public school to
poly prep nice which is a private school
yeah it is a little scholarship
but that place was not like public
school like i kind of stuck out like a
sore thumb like all the kids had money
and they they knew each other from like
pre-k when they got into the show and i
came in
in eighth grade it's tough yeah which is
a random year and i was playing number
two on the girls varsity as an eighth
grader and everyone's like who the [ __ ]
is this girl and i was like trying to
make friends being a little weirdo i
never really fit in and then my coach
told me if you want to go pro you need
to move to florida yeah why florida
because they're hitting so many more
balls
because it's outdoors and it's like the
best players they go train in florida
okay it's like where they have all these
um schools and stuff that are yeah where
it's like hey you wake up at five and
just start hitting balls
which school told you this the the
private your private school coach the
coach at polly prep was also my private
coach that's crazy see that's how the
kids do it tennis is bonko's to me but
it's bonko's because
now people we're starting to learn with
like naomi osaka
sports is so [ __ ] abusive yeah but
like they teach you basically like don't
have any emotions keep pushing yourself
past your limit listen to all these
coaches let them control you and anyway
like i was watching this culture i got
fired up just hearing it i was like damn
was i i was like i would fall for a cult
yeah
like where they'd be like you're gonna
be the greatest you just have to trust
me yeah i mean it ain't you had
vengeance
so it's like
no one tells me
sicilians so like i was trying to get
revenge at an early age
[Laughter]
yeah so i get to florida and basically
my only job is wait you did it bro i got
my parents they didn't know any better
i'm the oldest kid and they're like this
is nancy's dollar store my dad is like
we gotta get her hold on you're in
eighth grade i so at this point i was at
poly for two years so for tenth grade i
was fifteen i got sent down to florida
you went down the floor and what what
are you ranked at at that point i was
ranked i was ranked um
like top one top 50 in the nation are
you just playing
uh school matches or are you also
playing individual like tournaments no
school now i'm i'm playing international
tournaments in florida so i'm working on
getting an international girls 18 and
under ranking so then if you if you get
top there you go pro yeah so but you're
just instilled with all this fear like
your parents are paying so much money
for you to be here they took a second
mortgage out of their house for you to
be successful don't be lazy so i i was
just in crazy mode like i wake up before
practice go for a jog practice three
hours go eat practice another three
hours go to the gym
kind of do online school but not really
yeah like i've didn't do school for two
years i'm being honest um
wait what school were you technically
enrolled in i couldn't tell you so this
is how they this is how they do it when
you're training everybody gets set up
for that yeah are you down there by
yourself yeah so i was what i was part
of a house it was like a house that the
coach owned with like 12 players and we
all it was kind of like a little family
yeah yeah
where in florida was crazy this was in
um destin florida it's like between um
miami fort lauderdale area it's [ __ ]
hot we're doing planks on hard courts
and just like third degree burning
it's like how bad do you want it damn
and most girls are just the companies
wasn't
no this is different different coach so
i've had a lot of coaches over the years
and they also when i got there they made
a lot of changes to my game they were
kind of like we don't like this about
your game that about your game and i
didn't do well with the changes yeah
they wanted to change my grip i was
having trouble and then i got ranked top
like 250 in the world
for 18 and unders which is good it's
good that's crazy that's great
one of those say tennis is one of those
things where if you're like
the gap between 250 and 1 is like
bananas right well it's funny it's all
mental like if you saw professionals who
were 250 verse 1 you wouldn't be able to
say his best
but mentally there is a but also with
tennis if you're not top 100 you're not
making money yeah yeah you can't because
you're entrepreneurial you have to pay
for the travel you have to pay for your
coach it's not like the [ __ ] knicks
who are sitting on the bench making
millions of dollars
like you only get paid when you win not
trying to shade the knicks but like we
all understood did you get any
endorsements at all so i was endorsed by
dunlop and reebok what you got all free
[ __ ] i got some free [ __ ] what
and you could like break a racket every
now and then it was fun it's pretty
awesome i always wondered about like pro
sports like do they get new cleats every
game i'd want new [ __ ] everything it's
like christmas the first day of the
season when they give you [ __ ] but um
i eventually had a mental breakdown as
one does yeah okay when he's a really
good doctor you know there's a fantastic
documentary on netflix that just came
out like yesterday with marty fish yes
yeah i'm watching it yeah it's fun
i'm on it um
because tennis it's a sport i think it's
very similar to stand up in a way
ride with me on this
where you're alone out there performing
you have the variable of the other
player just like the variable of the
people in the crowd and then tennis is
the only sport where you like freak out
and start talking to yourself like a
crazy person which is basically what
stand up is sure and then you're
traveling alone every weekend to
different places you're only as good as
like your last performance your last
match of course and something about
stand up i was like oh this is eerily
calm for me yeah yeah yeah compared to
the pressure of tennis of course of
course but i basically have a mental
breakdown in curacao um i just curacao
where's that who the [ __ ] knows i just
found this
it's in like the west indies yes holy
[ __ ] you've got like a new hot spot
everybody's going you're [ __ ] doing
it you're cooking you're going around
i'm doing well but i'm like
one of those fancy sports schools where
they go who cares like you don't have to
go to class just become the best athlete
you can exactly but you have so much
pressure to win on you it's crazy and i
was like trying to change my forehand
grip and then whenever the match would
start i'd get really tight and i would
slice it this is like very tennis
and i was getting disappointed in myself
i was giving i was having a lot of
performance anxiety yes and um for
anyone who's experienced performance
anxiety it's [ __ ] up because like in
practice you're great sure everyone's
like okay just do it in a match and then
the magic [ __ ] try and you're like
you get paralyzed and then people are
like you're crazy [ __ ] and as i've
learned later in life i've learned that
like
there's been a lot of reasons why i have
performance anxiety it wasn't just i
woke up one day i mean parts that are
just genetic that's way too dark but
parts of it is also like i've had
coaches like throw water at me i've had
coaches make me run until i cramped up
i've had a lot but at the time this is
what the cult [ __ ] is like you're like
this is what you have to do oh yeah
you're fully invested like see samantha
across the court she served all night
what did you do so you're just in this
psychotic break
that's a lie i'd end up fighting a coach
for sure
i did i would i would get into fights on
the court because he'd yell something at
me and i'd be like [ __ ] you and we'd get
into fights during the match so when did
you officially quit so at 16 i'm ranked
high internationally but um i started
just crying at night
and sometimes your body will tell you
what your mind isn't telling you i was
like losing weight because i was like
working hard so much
and finally i just like had a breakdown
i was like i want to go home
and
this was like a movie moment where i get
back and it's me and my dad again
the beginning of the journey back at the
park slope house back in park slope your
house 17 18 i was 16. so what's your car
what's your do you go back to high
school
i'm about to tell you
he's on the edge of his seat he's like
what happened i really am man you got me
hooked with this
so my dad takes me to tennis court he's
so dramatic but he's like
i'm gonna hit this ball to you and
you're to hit it back and you're going
to tell me if you want to quit or if you
want to keep playing and regardless what
you do i'm still going to love you
[Music]
so you know crazy [ __ ] was like we got
to keep going yeah yeah
because i put too much into it so
this is when it gets kind of fun my mom
is a principal she so she knows other
principles and i'm in the middle middle
of a year i started hostessing at a
korean restaurant in brooklyn
to finish my online schooling to then
start a new school
the school that was really good as a
great tennis team they only had a boys
team
but because of title nine if a girl is
good enough you have to let her on the
team like if i win my way up to the team
so it's called the beacon school on the
upper west side i show up
i win a bunch of matches and we end up
winning beating dudes knocking them off
yeah i love you
what disney are you [ __ ] watching
get me 300 words on this let's go
what are we doing so i come from like
what are we doing
holy [ __ ] i come from being like the
bottom of the bottom to then like
finding this new community of these like
cool guys they would joke we got on the
court they'd be like take it easy on her
because they knew to me i was like if i
lose this [ __ ] who smokes weed
all day and played high school a couple
times i'll i'll end it yeah was there
any decent male players on their team
like they're near your level there was
always like one or two top guys on each
team um and with the guy the guys on
your team were cool to you you didn't
have to like they were beyond cool
because i also was training with them
like the new york city community is
pretty small where like i would train
with them they knew what i was and um
see i like that angle even better
because normally in the movie they would
be like bully you until you earn their
respect but that's what these guys pull
off the problems because we trained
together so they knew i was crazy they
respected me and we had a good bond and
and we weren't the like horse man or
probably prep kids like we were the
public school like these kids who came
from queens who just are like actually
talented i love that like underdog
fantastic
so get william defoe on the phone
he's gonna be the coach i'm already
casting i'm sorry
but then you know there's gonna be drama
when someone's doing well manscaped
manscaped manscape i'll say it one more
time shout out to the good people at
manscape with that skin safe technology
yeah you know kippy it's cuddling season
is coming up
fireplace is going getting snuggly
bumping uglies there's a chill in the
air you don't want to be down there with
leaves all over your yard if you know
what i mean i gotta run
down there you want to get the manscape
4.0 and clean it up for the fall yeah i
used it this morning i'm not even lying
use it this morning got two nice fresh
quail eggs down there if you want to
take a gander hit me up ooh the peaches
are in season oh dude i lie i do it in a
[ __ ] it's waterproof it's got the light
on it's the at the end you know you're
not gonna cut yourself and i've said
i've gone on record a bunch i was a
standard blade and cream man up until up
until the lawnmower were four points
shaving like al capone over here
i got my legs up on the stairs uh the
performance package includes the weed
whacker to crop your worst weeds uh of
the the near the near the ear and nose
trimmer that's the best i love that
thing
[ __ ] you that thing cooks daddy cooking
yeah it's great um you can seal the deal
with manscapes they have the for um
they have the skin safe technology uh
the crop preserver the ball deodorant
keeps a nice fresh everything you know
you can't be opening it up and smell
like the swamp down there you know no
so you check out all your manscape stuff
uh you'll get 20 off and free shipping
with promo code garbage at manscaped.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the promo code garbage manscape.com make
your balls a priority this fall choose
manscape your balls will thank you yes
they will do it
gang this podcast is brought to you by
the good people at stamps.com the best
in a biz that's right can't be the best
in the biz and they don't want you
wasting time in the post office nope
when you could be all making money with
your small business that's why you got
to get on stamps.com kippy straighten
them out yeah guys as we're small
business owners we use stamps.com that's
what we sent all the merch out with the
track it's it's so easy foley can do it
foley's in here printing stuff out i
don't know how he does it but he i mean
you're the master shipper over there
that easy kids guys all you need is an
internet proof
yeah there you go it's perfect it's the
best ad co-sign i can ever give holy
proof and fully appreciate it's fully
proof he did eat the laptop but still
um guys all you need is the uh the
printer um internet and a computer and
you can send if you're in your car you
can be in a hotel room you can be in an
office your house wherever it is it's
easy peasy hotel business center within
yes within minutes you're up and running
printing official postage for any letter
any package any size
anywhere big man what about them deals
they got with usps and ups hmm let me
think yeah you save money on both of
those [ __ ] i told you toby an idiot
i don't know why of course they you say
dude you can save so much money on
posters just by doing it this way and
you plot you can set it up i know you're
busy you run a small business you
they're just you're not hanging out in
the post office like there should be two
or three of you wear a lot of hats this
way you can whatever you're shipping out
you can set up and they'll come pick it
up right for you you don't even need to
go to post office no more oh that's
right you save time and money with
stamps.com there's no risk and with our
promo code garbage you'll get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
wow they sent it to us a little package
comes got the promo code
it's fantastic it's easy peasy no
long-term commitments or contracts so
just go to stamps.com click the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in the words garbage you know it
you love it that's stamps.com promo
codegarbagestamps.com never go to the
post office again now back
so i think there were some girls who
played but they were like short hair
more like butchy like and i had like
long hair and i was like girly so it
caused more of a stir in the media
so we win in the media what are you
talking really well like new york times
wrote an article that was like she plays
with the boys and rivals don't like it
because other schools started to get
[ __ ] pissed because we won the whole
new york city athletic league
championship or whatever [ __ ] jesus and
they were like it's not fair that you
have you're a ringer on your team that's
a girl like we want our girls who are
ringers on our team and i'm like wait
what are we fighting for right now why
were there was there any other per any
other people
that were as accomplished as you so
there were other schools there were some
some like one or two or three girls that
were really good on other teams but they
basically were like this isn't fair they
didn't like that i was a ringer on their
team because they they were saying girls
should not be able to play with the guys
because it's a lose-lose because if they
beat me it's like they were supposed to
and if they lose to me they lost a girl
but in my head i'm like it's a lose-lose
me playing a freshman who doesn't play
tennis seriously like if i lose to him
that's horrible sure yeah yeah so it was
a weird i mean gender aside wouldn't you
have to be recognized just based on
skill your international accomplishment
well that's the thing with tennis it's
not physical so like yeah at some point
like they could serve harder than me but
tennis they joke it's not a joke it's
like a quote that the chord is six
inches from ear to ear so i go in these
courts and i would just like
play with their head
one guy broke three rackets at the end
of our match
but i was used to this when i was
younger you guys look a little scared i
loved it i'm [ __ ] 11 years old i got
i went to a tennis camp and i had a
crush on this one guy he was like the
other good player and the whole time i
was like too nervous to talk about that
guy yeah
i was like he was really good
send me the signs
i know how i'll get his love all
humiliated in public
so we end up
at the end of the week where i was like
too nervous to talk to him
we had a tournament yeah and it's it is
a movie i [ __ ] meet up in the in the
movie i'm putting him on a rival team in
the city yes that's somebody you meet
you you meet an addict or maybe i i see
him again years later at this tournament
i don't know if we're jumping ahead
i mean
i appreciate your notes
that might be in the sequel i mean i
need to have some creative control of my
project you signed the story over to us
it's an antony it's an antoini project
right now
we got three thousand dollars raised
already here hear me out on this instead
of a host instead of a hostess job you
get a wasting job and we call it service
i'm obsessed
i'm obsessed that's really great that's
good that's really great service i am so
i played this kid i was like 13 14. i
play him at the end
and i win and i have such a crush on him
and at the end of the match he breaks
two of his rackets and won't even make
eye contact with me i never and that was
like my relationship but my dad was
always like never let a boy distract you
so i'd be like fighting these weird
feelings but then fast forward my dad
said he heard him at a tournament go and
he saw me and he goes that's the only
girl that ever beat me so like he
remembers me yeah there you go
he remembers me i'll never forget the
one i beat him my neighbor uh she was a
girl growing up and she would wrestle
and
she would we would go to like because i
was friends with her she would [ __ ]
these kids up and then they would they
would go cry like under the scores table
and i'm like this it was
she was like [ __ ] dudes i wrestled a
girl i wrestled a girl in eighth grade
did you win yeah i won this was two
weeks ago
wrestling's next level though like
that's some intimate [ __ ] with me like
i'm sure oh yeah
but
the final thing was at the end there was
a singles tournament for new york city
and they go hannah can't play on the
boys she has to play with the girls and
i had all this pressure to show like i
deserve to play with the boys
and i had to play this girl she ended up
playing for arizona or something and i
lost the first like five games and i was
down five two and i'm like i just felt
so much [ __ ] pressure like there was
there was all this press like daily news
and all this stuff i ended up
there was pres and
it's crazy i feel like people talk about
this in entertainment too sometimes when
it's you're getting all this attention
it's actually the scariest and i was
like forgetting how to hit my backhand
and i was just so scared but i won the
match and then i got a full ride to the
university of wisconsin
pretty good full ride and you went there
and played tennis in college go badgers
yes
but it is trash because i didn't have to
pay [ __ ]
and my dad was very happy
you're going to what do you mean
he finally got a couple of them dollars
back though it's florida i literally
joke all the time i'm like can i have a
20 and he's like you owe me 450 thousand
dollars i'm like is that how parenting
works dad
anyway yeah it's going in the book
though
that is a [ __ ]
banana
but i did end up playing some
professional tournaments when i was in
florida so i kind of like checked that
off the box and then at 22
i decided to go back to new york city
and retire
higher 22 retired yeah look at that yeah
pretty [ __ ] cool
yeah pretty but i retired to become an
intern at a fashion like magazine
which one i don't know it was like i got
the secret that was like a fashion
boutique
called bird in brooklyn okay they were
really mean and i went from being like
captain of my team to being like if you
don't get me coffee right now i will
throw it in your face and i was just
like this is weird
um but yeah that's a movie too
i mean we haven't even hit the reality
tv [ __ ] yet yeah it's not then
we're sitting on a gold mine here get an
nda from her
york the sequel you're working in the in
the fashion business and now it's off
the racket
that's pretty good gets taken over by
terrorists and you have some kind of
magic tennis racquet with grenade balls
and now you're [ __ ] getting that i
mean that's from wonder woman nice guys
guys no bad ideas at a brainstorm
some action the writer's room here guys
come on let's get it cracking all right
let's get into some are you garbage
questions that's an insane background we
can't from that
we're missing eight years in between
then and now yeah and then she went on
to host to be on two reality tv shows or
something crazy crazy
bonkos
we gotta find out because i didn't hear
i couldn't get any go i was just that
was just a [ __ ] enthralling [ __ ]
amazing story there was no garbage in
that now we got
find her parents gave her away at 14.
i think she just distracted us
with the sports illustrated story yeah
this is what she's right now we're going
to start growing that's called 30 30
right there oh that's a good 30 for 30.
liam schreiber call us
liam does the good announcers
all right um
so you sold the house
in
park stock
i'm recapping no i know i know i know
big man what street was that on over
there garfield place between seventh and
eighth
that's pretty a block away from prospect
park and your grocery store over there
growing up key food
key food goes either way we found out i
think they're individually owned so it's
a real hit or missed how was it was it
all right or was it like non-tiled
concrete floor
a starbucks did try to open and the
whole community was in arms because they
were like we do small businesses but now
it's like all about business i don't
know where that has to do with garbage
but
that's that is it's like hipster garbage
yeah yeah exactly exactly we had a
connecticut muffin
what the [ __ ] the connecticut muffin
exactly jesus oh that weird yeah we're
small boutiquey type what kind of car
did your dad drive
ford
[Laughter]
and do you have a car now um i just got
my first car but i don't drive what is
it what do you mean i got an audi i
don't have a license i lost my license
it expired and then i failed my test
what how did we able to buy a car
because my fiance
i bought it so my fiance can drive me
around
okay but are you allowed to buy a car if
you don't have a license i've is this a
citizen's arrest what's happening
toby
becker toby hey fat boy
so growing up in new york city we didn't
have driver's ed or anything so i never
got my license at 24 my dad was like you
have to get your license
i got it in the bronx it was sketchy i
ended
railing the curb and the lady was like
jesus christ and she passed me then i
never really drove and then during the
pandemic it expired didn't know i just
had to press something online yeah yeah
and um i had to redo my test and i
failed it did they tell you that they're
like they're sitting there with a clip
they have this receipt for you and then
they write fail or pass and they just
hand it to you i didn't even get to the
parallel parking the guy was like let's
turn the car around
i've seen all i need to see they're
going the wrong way and we got stuck on
the median
they have all their like your history so
he goes you had your license before and
i was like yep yep i tried to make him
laugh and he didn't respond those guys
are tough yeah those guys are tough yeah
bad i mean
i like apparently the first turn the
left turn i just like kind of went right
on the yellow lines apparently you're
not supposed to do that so it's good
you're not driving it's good your your
fiance has a license yeah you got an
audi yeah pretty nice thank you pretty
classy thank you suv reality tv money
yes nice yeah but this is like this
falls into like trashy newman she bought
it out
actually it's not bought at least when
that one so important information so
you're the
the first successful thing you started
doing in uh entertainment was
uh working on the bravo shows right
so i ended up going into sales as my
first real job when i was making money
big data cold calling
cold calling coffees for closes
and um were you pushing
i was pushing
digital marketing for small businesses
couldn't tell you what it does sure of
course but i was like i made people
laugh i was like good energy and i just
started selling a [ __ ] ton like i was
making
six figures 22 years old what but i
[ __ ] hated it and i would i just
hated it i felt like i was back in
tennis where like if you had a win
you're happy if you didn't you hated
yourself and i'm like i'm doing the same
[ __ ] and i was more interested in the
creative stuff so then i
went to a marketing company that was
really boring and i quit
finally i'm like i want to do video that
was the thought i just want to do video
okay
and i believe in manifestation do you
boys believe in manifestation
to an extent yeah i mean i believe
i'm not trying to be all like crystal
[ __ ] it's more like if you put it
out there like you it's like after a
breakup and you think about your ex you
notice them everywhere sure it's like if
you think of something positive you
start noticing the opportunities
everywhere completely agree so i was
like in university of wisconsin i did
some sports broadcasting because i know
sports i like being from the camera i
was like i want to do that again
this company called this media company
for millennial women wanted some funny
videos okay so i sent some funny videos
and they wanted five years experience of
a video producer and i know how to edit
but i didn't know [ __ ] so it just came
with a bunch of ideas so this company
paid me 300 a week and they were like
can you make funny videos and memes and
tweets and i was like i'm the funny
friend in my group text like i come from
a funny family i can do this i can
figure it out and then
i
i started my tweets started to go viral
and i started to create videos i started
to meet comedians in the city and that
was my your bridge my bridge
yeah and then i started a podcast and
then i found out that i got casted on a
reality tv show so i was like okay this
could be my platform to do what i really
love to do which is make people laugh
but you already had a good chunk of cash
from the sales thing
i had decent cash and also i hadn't
spent any money on college because i
took all my parents money and were you
living at home at the time when you were
doing the sales thing yeah i was living
at home so what did you do was there
anything that you bought irresponsibly
when you first got a bunch of money how
do i say this i am the cheapest
[ __ ]
i don't spend any money on anything
except food
um
yeah i don't spend and i don't spend
money on it that's very classy
is that what do you mean 22 year old kid
making six figures do you have any idea
what i would have bought we went
shopping and he was like let's get these
strawberries and i'm like those
strawberries are nine dollars and he's
like you need to grow up oh yeah you're
not so that's i don't think that's
classy like i'm a little crazy how did
you get here today
um ubering and food
i will sacrifice
i like it
i love how i feel like i'm in a test
right now for real because he's exiting
stuff off yeah he's shaking his head a
little
those notes mean nothing it just says
jelly beans
he's playing tic-tac-toe with himself
and he's
somehow damn it
this guy's killing me
[Laughter]
oh my god
kippy
what was my first big purchase i guess i
finally got a studio apartment after one
year into reality tv i started renting a
studio apartment but it was in queens so
that's kind of trashy yeah
[Laughter]
what really
wow imagine that it was long enough
studio and queen i
going
mean
astoria it was it was long island city
but still
that's no that's yeah i love how she's
like well i
i thought she said she bought i was like
well yeah that's where i thought you
were going you started renting a studio
apartment in queens credit score is good
yeah credit score is good credit cards i
got credit cards
roughly what's the credit limit credit
limit oh combined all said and done i
don't know because i don't really spend
money but i've never been in trouble
with it okay
see that's a classy person's answer
american express um
no chase sapphire that's not fire pretty
good that is pretty good is it a metal
card or is it plastic it's in between
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about i'm talking about it's not oh yeah
i've seen one i've seen one
i used to shine i used to shine the
shoes of a man who had one i said what's
that mister
that's a credit card son no no but so
i'm i just turned 30. i didn't start
making money until like real money until
i was 28.
um you said you were making six figures
at 22. that's real money yeah but you
know
wow that means you're making real real
money
this kid's got some cash no but
how much cash you got on you right now
you got some 20s from stand up but the
fun part about all this is i got on a
reality tv show
and then they got me on a talk show on
bravo and i was like oh my god i've made
it yeah and then um it all fell apart
and i lost both jobs yeah there's not a
lot of legs to those reality tv shows no
no no no no yeah but you still got a
shitload of episodes out of it thank you
thank you yeah it's great yeah i i
didn't believe it i had two great
seasons and one like just terrible
season um but i got out alive
there you go yeah
i love it
i had a girl who was on the bachelor
she didn't she threw a huge party for
like the viewing party yeah i went to
high school with her
and she got voted off in the first
[ __ ] episode and then the party ended
with her crying in the back of the bar
oh my god and we're all like why did you
invite the whole world
out to this you knew how this ended yeah
you were there
you were there she was the first one off
it was like she didn't even make it
through the credits
yeah the fact that she was even there
would tell don't they film maybe she
thought there'd be more screen time
because you don't know what they're
going to show because they filmed for
like 12 hours that first night i don't
even think she unpacked like she was
still
she got she got
because i could see like throwing a
party and then they start a new
storyline that you're not aware of where
everyone's talking [ __ ] about you like
that happened to me where i would be
like this is embarrassing but that [ __ ]
knew she knew yeah she knew she wanted
some negative attention maybe all
attention's decent attention that's true
she gets to play the victim afterwards
yes which i'm a big fan
quite honest with you hey listen she can
play whatever role she wants it was open
bar
[Laughter]
that's a sin tough break got four
margaritas yeah two more rum and cokes
please
all right
what do you got kip um let's see
how old were you the first time you had
lobster
i was young because we'd go to montauk
when i was younger we lived we'd be in
brooklyn and we'd go out to shelter
island i'd go to your grandfather's to
see some of my grandfather's that would
be the vacation plan bar yeah i go the
clan barn montauk pretty good pretty
young i do remember my dad still reminds
me once
i got fred flounder he got lobster and i
was like i want that and he gave me his
lobster and to this day he's like i gave
you my [ __ ] lobster yeah this guy
really holds a grudge all right the 400
grand the lobster
remember when you had the last ball of
cereal huh
you don't think i like frosted flakes
now you know where i get my cheap ass
from that's good that's good i think
that i'm sticking to my assessment i
think that's a sign of of class saving
money wow okay
you're saving money and cheapness or two
things
um do you call it mini golf or putt-putt
mini golf okay is that classy
putt-putt trashy mini golf yeah
putt-putt in the south they say that
when someone first said putt-putt i was
like excuse me it's
it sounds like you're talking to bless
you yeah it's insane uh as an athletic
person are there any games like
putt-putt that you excel at like
skee-ball
or great question i'm quite good at
ping-pong like i won't i mean yeah i
won't i won't be a real i won't beat a
real ping-pong player because they have
like real technique but like if we're
drunk at a bar i am throwing down yeah
and just whooping ass she's got people
running i'll be there all night and i'm
very competitive like i'll go out and
i'll be like okay first to five get in a
line and i'd be like next next victim
next victim and then i'll go home all
sweaty yeah sounds like a real cool hang
on yeah yeah
and i'm like
having a good time with marital ova over
here huh jesus christ we're trying to
get some cheesesteak egg rolls in here
what the [ __ ] let's get a picture of
beer you guys the guys
the guys get very hyped up about it like
i'll compete i'm gonna beat her i'm
gonna beat her so then it becomes yeah
then you gotta eat then you have to show
up gotta own them um i actually am this
is kind of classy of me i'm good at golf
i'm going to go are you i'm i'm a 15
handicap what
yeah no because when i was younger in
shelter island we played tennis and golf
and i kind of had to choose between
so um
i'm basically a retired old man and i
get along very well with older men who
are in finance i'd know i could talk the
talk i watch a golf channel on sundays
how often do you get out
um recently because i've been traveling
the brooklyn the brooklyn thing is real
misleading i think you're pretty close
wait you're making me blush
i mean what i don't know are we were we
doing in two different shows
she's got an audi and can't drive it
yeah but still the shelter island thing
that's her grandfather the shelter i
don't think is her grandfather that's i
think that's even makes it more classy
because there's a little bit of heritage
they're not some renters out there on
the weekends there's some legacy there's
some legacy
first of all i don't know which shelter
island is but it sounds haunted
[Laughter]
oh god all right let's see
your family ever changed their name
anybody in your family ever changed
their name great question so my mom's
last name is deleo italian my dad is
like russian austrian polish jewish he's
burner
they may have been changed in ellis
island to shorten them up they may have
nothing known but nobody nobody's first
you don't have a cousin that like
changed her name she was named sheila
and she changed her name
[Laughter]
um no no name change is pretty
straightforward not a lot of drama in
the family not bad so there's nobody in
your immediate family or cousins that
doesn't speak to each other anything
like that
there actually
is not it's super boring
telling you these kids are right
any male family members cousins uncles
have ponytails
no
any runaways in the family
no but one of my cousins has been
studying abroad for a while
an eerily long time she's at the sore
bowl he's been volunteering in africa
for a while wow come on
does anybody in your family not trust
the banks
[Laughter]
my dad is queasy about the stock market
but my brother's been getting him to be
more trustworthy okay okay
any instruments as a kid
um piano very
a little bit a little bit of trumpet i
thought it was gonna be the easiest one
because there's only three buttons it's
actually the hardest plus the plunger at
the end yes yes any magicians in the
family um god no
yeah this is come on do you put potato
chips on a sandwich yes
especially tuna
i [ __ ] with that oh that just made my
blood wrong
um oil and vinegar a little salt and
vinegar chip on it on a tuna sandwich
yes i'm doing that this weekend
i thought you were eating well
two to four i'll put it on wheat tuna
fish is protein i'll use vegan a's yeah
what's your mayonnaise um any and all
you do miracle whip
not not normally i do was it heinz
helmets helmets helmets sorry helmets
yeah those kids aren't right i didn't
even know what hellman's was
i just remember the age i don't do the
shopping in the family growing up would
you keep the butter on the counter or in
the refrigerator in the refrigerator
okay
interesting favorite salad dressing
um i don't eat salads
why not because it's rabbit food what do
you eat
come on i like dairy you don't eat
vegetables
i do but um salads are just like very
chewy um if i were to put something on
it that's that's one way to put it maybe
a
maybe a ranch
i know that's trashy but um it's better
than the other ones better than barbecue
sauce you're starting to work your way
down there yeah i'll give you that i
mean yeah it's rabbit
that's like something a dad said in the
80s i mean i do eat sweet green when i
have to okay that's a fantastic uh
fantastic harvest bowl yeah do you drink
recommend um not really i did when i was
on reality tv because i got paid for it
okay but um i've always been better at
eating than drinking put icing in your
wine
no no okay
not bad
never bought anything at an auction
only um
for like a charity thing once
[Laughter]
i don't care how many probably a b50 i
don't care how many licenses she doesn't
have
what was a charity
probably something
i do love like mental health stuff come
on yeah come on what are we doing
[Laughter]
drag i have a pot and this burner i
apologize
bringing you down here this is
ridiculous
oh god this is ridiculous i mean i i i
am like kind of the country club
brooklyn i guess because not a lot of
people would play tennis or golf yeah
that's weird for me that's what i'm
saying it's my shelter island experience
that i think elevated my culture
okay you guys are putting a lot of stock
in there but i did go to the other
island you guys i went to university of
wisconsin that's
yeah no no it's not that's a good fight
i mean it's that's a good score it is
football
great football program it is considered
one of the ivies of the midwest arguably
people would have hey that's the
trashiest thing you've said in the last
45 minutes yeah there we go next you're
gonna say it was a satellite
university of wisconsin long island
but a lot of duck hunting a lot of
cheese curds a lot of beer sure simple
life sure love that yeah it's okay
spotted cow yes spot a cow i did i
wanted to just see what what middle
america was like see if it could enhance
my um perspective of the world you know
yeah do you steal
candy bars anything like that for the
thrill airport
no i do i did eat my roommates leftover
food a couple too many times though but
that's i would get them back immediately
next day i'd buy them whatever i ate if
you if you go out to a restaurant and
you don't finish meal do you take
leftovers home
yeah
so you have no problem eating out of
your
then roommates
leftover containers after they had eaten
out of it yeah they're okay with that my
roommates would get halal food late at
night would not eat it and then the
morning i'd be like thank you halal food
is
arguably you're crushing half a gyro
from your [ __ ] roommate a whole gyro
wait did they eat it it was their bite
they might have they hit alone then they
passed out while eating it and then next
day
i don't want to have to go outside for
food that's here we go
[Laughter]
do you guys not eat street meat of
course
not after some [ __ ] kid from
williamsburg yeah that's nuts
what the [ __ ]
that's not i mean was it in the fridge
yes yes
yes it was in the fridge i heated it up
were your roommates anybody we know at
the time no all right
no comics no comics hmm have you ever
attended a birthday dinner at a hibachi
restaurant when i was young with like
poly prep kids but once i was out of
that i didn't touch it holy [ __ ] going
out to restaurants in high school like
that it was like birthday parties that's
that would have been what
chuck e cheese like everybody else that
in high school bozo i don't know that
sounds pretty classy to me actually i
did have a pretty epic birthday party
once
they got a pony in brooklyn so the kids
were like riding a pony up and down the
street just a big dog
a weird looking dog and then they got
all these goldfish and they put it in
like a little blow up pool and the kids
got to capture the gold goldfish there
was a lot of death that day yeah but i
mean those things don't last now they
say it out loud i think i'm gonna get
cancelled from that party peter peter's
coming for me um take a goldfish throw
it on the concrete
brush your teeth in the shower no god no
pee in the shower yes okay
pee in the pool yes
and hot tub which is kind of classy that
i'm in hot tubs no it's not it's hot you
pee in a [ __ ] hot tub it's already
hot i also pee and hot
what the hot it water makes you want to
pee
too small scientific toby's mad at me
like we go in hot tubs every night
we're gonna we're doing good
dude come on this movie comes out i like
that it's chlorinated
i think it's classy that i've been in
enough hot tubs to have a peeing routine
hot tubs aren't that classy depending on
the application of the hospital
you have a standalone hot tub that's
ultimate that's what this show was
there's there's not enough water to
disperse the pee that's what started
this show it is that was like one of the
first questions that was that started
the show a standalone hot tub is trash
pretty vocal about peeing in hot tubs
because the reality show was a lot of
like summer [ __ ] so i i would just be
like going to go pee in the hot tub with
carl in it and that's just what i would
do you would say that yeah
that was fun for me
i would just be looking at the camera
guy be like they'd be like you're
disgusting
when you were an athlete did you ever
use those ice baths did i see
celebrities
yeah it was horrible they did yeah they
would it was like a hazing thing where
after practice they would force us to be
in for five minutes the first minutes
horrible then your body starts going
numb and then you're kind of just
sitting in it and then you go outside
and then it's [ __ ] wisconsin weather
so you could die of pneumonia but it was
worth it for the sport yes it was that's
awesome that's pretty cool
here's a question athlete
what's your favorite gatorade flavor
great question um i have to go with okay
my actual favorite is mango which you
can't you won't find a lot it's very
rare sure but next i'd have to go with
classic icy blue yeah nice because
you're a [ __ ] you know you don't have
your head up your ass no
but i would drink it and i would get it
all over myself every match what would
you what would you drink it on the match
so apparently nowadays gatorade's
considered like crack cocaine and it has
too much sugar but as a kid all we did
was drink gatorade it was in my [ __ ]
veins
jacked up yeah [ __ ] loved it so i
would drink so much gatorade they would
have like a little water on the side but
i think water is boring i would just be
chugging gatorade so that's what's in
your little squirt bottle yeah gatorade
powerade doesn't hit the same frame no
no no
no
offensive
yeah but nowadays they have
body armor and like less sugary
yeah
they were like this stuff is bad for
children oh yeah yeah yeah yeah gatorade
uh
are you tsa pre-checked
i
am currently i have um what's the other
one clear i have clear
no fly list yeah
but i'm supposed to get on tsa pre
um but i've been procrastinating she
bought a plane but she can't fly yeah
that's you guys
you get me i lost my pilot's license
couldn't parallel park this thing saved
my life
you get cash back when you when you make
a purchase no
yeah you're classy very clean
how do you feel about parmesan truffle
fries
i [ __ ] with that okay anything with
truffle i [ __ ] with i like it that's
classy right
fake truffle real truffle i'll take you
there though oh okay
i've recently gotten a truffle hot sauce
that i've been [ __ ] with you do hot
sauce um isn't that at the bottom just a
little bit it's called trust right yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
how hot so it's an instagram ad um i got
it for free i did i did get it for free
oh there she goes
[Music]
here we are i mean
the question is you're doing sponsored
are you doing sponsored hot sauces i do
i just did a sponsored post for body
armor yesterday i do a lot of stuff
that's why she [ __ ] ran out of bodies
they're doing 50 less sugar than
gatorade
toby cut that always she holds up a
pound of sugar
i also gatorade i want to know from you
guys i do sponsored ads for dildos
so sex toys because the average
influencer doesn't want to do them and
these guys have a lot of money for
marketing i know shout out to adam and
eve coming up
and i have a following and i'm a
comedian so i'm like please i would love
to
and also it's like it talks about sexual
wellness whatever you know it's
important so i do
sex toy ads all the time and that's how
i bought my audi yeah really
gotta respect it i like it i mean i'm
not like jamming it inside of me
you like what you see click the link in
my bio
i do not have an oldie fans yet but um
if things go bad you never know hmm it's
fantastic any hoarders in the family
no but i i'm not the cleanest i'm a
little messy
i think we all are though i mean we're
creative you know every everybody says
i'm an artist
um but yeah no i'm not clean i'm not ocd
but i was raised with the italian family
my mom would just like clean everything
she loves cleaning so i felt like i was
giving back to the family okay a little
trail of mess
what's the coffee pot situation at your
place now and do you have your own place
now do you guys yo you and your fiance
live together i'm living with my fiance
nice um in lower east side okay
and
he does pretty well he does well i'm not
a
big coffee drinker
i drink chai lattes and matcha lattes
matcha's classy
oh [ __ ] my wife does
on the lower east side
there are moments when i'll be sitting
with my fans in the lower east side and
i'm like we're not cool enough to be
here like you need to you gotta put on a
tutu or something and like figure it out
yeah it's true you need like cool
fashion all the time that's like
breaking norms and like yeah something's
so insane where you're like he's i'm not
buying this you're but he's cool as [ __ ]
you're
cool dress guys you guys do belong down
there what do you mean oh my god thank
you are you guys shipping us as they say
what does that mean it means like to
support like you ship a relationship
like you you're
you you want the best for them 100. yeah
okay i've always been a big fan of
guys
has he been is there anything i should
know about him that i don't know i don't
know i don't even know him that well
suddenly you guys are going to bozo if
you're somebody you've never met him i
just know him to say hello to him but i
know he's a good-looking kid and a sharp
dresser
and maybe i would like to kiss him
if he were to be open to that do i find
him attractively i do
wait nobody asked me that
tommy cut the diaper
but you i appreciate the humble name you
guys do belong down there
i'm 42 episodes on bravo what do you
think if you don't belong in the lower
east side who does
no but it is very young and very cool
like it is gotcha very fashion for you
yes like so fashionable the point where
it's like people are walking you're like
what what's going on but they pull it
off it's wild oh yeah what's fashion
forward mean exactly you're backwards
the opposite
what does that mean fashion forward
means like you're creating the trends
you're not just copying you're not like
you're like yeah like you someone's
doing something crazy on the lower east
side and then like three months later
it's on the cover of vogue the same
style because they're the artists that
are like creating it's like you know
underground comedy yes yeah yeah yeah
give me a give me an example of
something that i'm not doing i mean she
can try i'm not dying like a bird cage
on your head and jinko's on your left
yeah you'll be like what is that person
even wearing and then what do i get
something like that
get down there's lower each side
kids on tick tock
is that a v-neck or just a a
scoop neck what's happening just gotta
get over that
i didn't know we were coming here to
insult each other
[Laughter]
it's a it's a loose whatchamacall this
has just come up loose scoop yeah this
has just come up um
a couple of fans have hit me up i gotta
start i gotta start doing collared
shirts for for the duration of my
fatness because this is a tough luck
it's bad
i like it or maybe it's fashion forward
i don't know yeah maybe just say they
don't get it it's fashion maybe in five
years fat guys with loose collars and
pre-diabetes neck is going to be going
to be on the cover of vote
how about that
i mean
sure i'm a runway model
ever see your parents french kiss
no
pretty good
ever in a mechanical bull
no you thought i had her dead the right
time
i've watched my friends but i'm like nah
my tennis career is too important dude
the whole vibe of this show has been
fully being like she's all class it's
like two detectives yeah and he's like
it's an open shut case and jimmy's like
nah there's more to this thing it's
people that we never think
oh well i'm a comedian so i obviously
hate myself so there has to be some
trash in there but you guys haven't i
haven't found it yet yet we're not going
anywhere
[Laughter]
do you have name brand luggage
no no no just like whatever some a
i i think at a young age i lost i've
lost important things i'm a little
forgetful so i don't like to put my
happiness into materialistic things that
could be disappeared or you know do you
have a retirement fund that you've set
up for yourself i do you do because my
brother's in finance so he told me i
have to is it a 401k
no but i have like an ira roth ira very
nice i also have one there's about 12
bucks
it's a bag but i do have one too
um
[Laughter]
all right you're you're at a restaurant
you're done yeah say you're having a
soda it's a pint glass yup will you
stuff your dirty napkin in the glasses
no no no no but i'll put the napkin on
the plate sometimes just to let people
know we're done we're done here yeah but
never not in the will you also this has
been highly debated on uh twitter over
the last couple of days
stacking the plates for the server
classy or trashy what do you think
i think that is
i think it's classy okay i think it's
classy
because you're trying to get out of
there you're helping a little bit i
don't think it's necessary right because
you know let her you know have a purpose
but um or him or him but i'll um move
move the plate sometimes to make it
easier for them but i'm not going to do
a full cleanup i like it yeah
not getting the bus pan out exactly
exactly how do you save an avocado
um you keep the pit in it yeah it's
smart
you keep the pit in it especially if you
make guacamole save the pit put it in
it's like the matrix right now
this is funny because
me being just a millennial white girl
you guys are like you're so classy yeah
i mean you're i mean you're blowing our
minds i'm just being an annoying
millennial avocado
me telling you how to save avocado is
bare minimum to be a millennial woman
sure of course of course bare minimum
avocado toast you have to be able to
handle that in your sleep any paintings
of your family together you have a
family painting no but my nan and papa
the italian side do have a couple
portraits together to show their love
portraits or paintings paintings of
portraits that's right but that's okay
yeah that's old school do they have the
pictures of like sinatra and the pope
and stuff like that they well sinatra's
always playing in the background um i
think there's a photo of them meeting
him once a little what yeah
i mean they're real italian
you got a picture you meeting sinatra i
think snatcher kissed my mom on the
cheek she tells a story a lot yeah
he's like breaking his [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and my nana is um very very beautiful my
grandma she's like sexy and um i've seen
her instagram oh yes nana's still got it
follow her you're being serious yeah my
nan is very very beautiful and she has
still knows she has a ton of stories of
just celebrity men like yankees just
like hitting on her and um that's
awesome yeah so that's cool so you're
both i don't know if that's class mike
my grandma has a
instagram full of like strokes which she
really does yeah is that classy or
trashy
you're a goddamn professional tennis
player what do you think this is my
friend this is my nana's instagram
she's a piece
i i got all i i mean i got an uber to
shelter island real quick
i got everything i need to
i mean what are we doing
i mean i've told you some you ever go
into sephora and get anything and then
and then leave with it no
i'd do that
get a couple samples and get it i got
one from patreon that my but you don't
uh you don't drink but but i do drink
sometimes uh it's from tt
it's just letters uh first question you
ever top off your white claw with vodka
give it a floater no it's a thing i'm
i'm kind of an old man
who's retired
in a
30 year old girl's body do you ever see
the bacon brothers in concert no i don't
know who you know what that is good
do you want it
you want to go next friday night i got
two front row tickets have you ever seen
a band twice in a row
no
never been on tour with the dad or
anything like that no burning man no
lollapalooza no
you floss every day
every three days damn this gets good
what have you turned
yeah i was trying to get i've yeah you
were asking me for i think it's because
i was an athlete i have a kind of a
disciplined mentality of course but um
you guys you miss i did reality tv i
know but uh yeah but i mean i did do it
strategically to i thought about that
like comedic career but i've done some
trashy things on tv i a a guy um i mean
peeing in the house you are technically
a reality tv star and that puts you into
i'm now trying to move i'm trying to
rebrand i'm in a randomification but um
i did have a guy that's classy i did
yeah he's classy that's what it is
i did have a guy working on yourself
what the [ __ ] i had a guy eat me out
on where the [ __ ] did this come from
on tv i mean it was like undercovers but
like you hear like you can hear me have
sex on tv wait what show's that summer
house the show is it on demand
season episode
but i do i did it in a like empowering
way that you know women should be able
to enjoy sex sure of course and
have fun with like like he's a hot model
and i was like yeah let him go down on
me like i felt like that was a very
feminist thing i didn't go down on him
um so for me i was kind of just changing
the world
through sex on tv when he whooped his
ass in table tennis yeah then i did beat
him in tennis then you run for president
let me know because i'm on board i like
i did get a drink thrown at me once but
i i didn't rebuttal i just walked away
yeah who threw the drink at you this
girl named amanda [ __ ] a man was it
on the show yeah she was mad because her
fiance was being rude to her and me and
i was like don't talk to me how you
talked to her and she got upset she
stood up for herself
kids are funny
it's an open and shut case over here
you know folks we gave it our best shot
i think we have a pretty good track
record of getting confessions out of
people on the show
uh hannah berner
top-notch class in my top-notch class is
this bad did i disappoint you guys no no
no no there's no right or wrong there's
just classy or garbage and you my friend
are the classiest i'll see you in the
lower east side
i'll see you in the hamptons
empowerment the athleticism everything
top shelf the plan the ira
wait so coming
coming from two seasoned comics as
someone who's greener in the industry
can i be a successful stand-up with this
kind of class yeah yeah for sure are you
talking to us are you sure i was talking
about
of course season the game a minute
you're already a successful comedian
you're doing great what are you talking
about better than us but i'm saying the
long term you know there's going to be
those ups and downs as dark times um
yeah no you we don't know what's going
on i've been we've been successful for
like two months yeah you said season i
started looking around for salt and
pepper
what
seasoned
you look like you've seen some [ __ ]
that's true
golden corral 1996. i do i did [ __ ] with
golden corral once all right stop
playing one take one trying to get you
out of here
ladies and gentlemen hannah berner what
an episode so much fun what do you got
coming up you want the folks out there
tonight go to hannahburn.com i got some
stuff in new jersey buffalo
um some west coast stuff and listen to
my podcast burning hell definitely love
to have you guys on it's a mental health
comedy pod love it
follow me at being burns anywhere where
i do my i express my art
that's even classy right now and dildo
hats
still pretty classy it's empowerment
2021
right get on board hannah burner
unbelievable kippy what do you got for
him uh cameron comedy on all social
media come to a live show i mean we got
[ __ ] live dates
merch the whole nine yards patreon check
it out guys we love you and we will see
you next week peace